yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and in this video I'll be explaining the
ending of the nun how the movie connects
to the rest of the country universe and
sets up a nun sequel and I'll be
revealing secret VALIC Easter eggs and
make sure you stay till the end where
I'll also explain the movie's big twist
if you're here for the first time do
subscribe for all my regular videos and
more upcoming horror videos too of
course
boilers ahead for the movie so take care
if you haven't seen it yet or tap here
to watch my freaky facts about the
making of the nun the big reveal at the
end of the nun is that French his real
name is Maurice and that he's the
french-canadian farmer whose exorcism
the Warrens discussed during their
lecture in the first conjuring movie
take Maurice here's a french-canadian
farmer had nothing more than a
third-grade education yet after he was
possessed spoke some of the best Latin
I'd ever heard sometimes backwards a
dark spirit made its home in this man
and like that an upside-down cross
started to appear from within his body
at the end of the nun we see the origins
of that cross inside maurices body by
the upside-down cross that's revealed on
the back of Frenchie's neck we also see
that during the final fight with VALIC
the demon nun vomited a snake into
Frenchie's mouth the demon Valek has a
number of names one of which is the
Marquess of snakes meaning he has the
power to summon and command snakes which
suggests that the snake VALIC puts into
French he means the demon possessed him
or can't control him
in fact the movies director Karen Hardy
has described Frankie as a film's secret
weapon and it's interesting that in the
nun French she works as a delivery man
to the Abbey which is a neat bit of
foreshadowing for how many years later
Maurice delivers that horrifying vision
of belong to Lorraine I had a vision in
a medieval
it was the same one I had seven years
ago
I had a premonition of your death in a
similar way to how the church closed the
gateway to hell at the time of the Duke
at the end of the film the portal in the
convent is closed when the blood of
Christ spills into the pool of water on
top of the opening sister Irene appears
to have defeated VALIC when she spits
holy blood all over the demon which
seems to send him back to Hell via the
Gateway in the comments floor but it
looks like she was a little too late as
right at the end it appears that Maryse
is now the vessel for foul act to escape
that ending was actually foreshadowed
near the start of the film when Frenchy
told sister Irene that the locals always
spit when the castles mentioned in order
to ward off evil and although French she
said it was an old and silly
superstition he spat on the ground
himself before entering the castle for
the first time James Wan has already
said he has a potential story in mind
for a nun sequel which would come back
to Lorraine's story in the two country
movies so far which means a nun sequel
could explore how far lack returns via
Maurice and could also illuminate just
why the demon is so interested in the
Warrens okay so we need to talk in some
more detail about sister Irene and how
the movie tease is a number of
connections between her and Lorraine
Warren first is the interesting
coincidence that taissa farmiga who
plays Irene is the real-life sister of
fear of Farmiga who plays Lorraine
taissa is around 21 years younger than
vera and with the nun set in 1952 about
19 years before the conjuring and 25
years before its sequel it seems
possible there could be some kind of
family connection between Irene and
Lorraine that might be revealed in the
next none or conjuring movie and
although during set visits from the
known cast and crew said there's no
connection they could just be trying to
keep things under wraps or give
themselves time to figure out exactly
how that'll work in a sequel
character-wise Irene's visions and
premonitions are similar to Lorraine
psychic abilities and could point to
their being related by blood or
otherwise connected then there's a very
interesting parallel and how the demonic
nun reveals itself to both Irene and
Lorraine phallic manifests itself to
Irene via a mirror during one of Iran's
visions in a similar way to how we see
Lorraine's vision of the demon in a
mirror during her Amityville seance the
nun movie also echoes the scene from the
conjuring to where the demon
shadow crawls along a wall before
physically appearing in the painting of
the nun where it attacks Lorraine in
this movie the nun shadow crawls along
the chapel wall before appearing in the
mirror behind Irene on top of that
during maurices exorcism which we see at
the end of the nun the way he grabs and
looks at Lorraine makes me wonder if he
senses a connection between her and
Irene who he knew from Romania or
perhaps in his terror he mistook
Lorraine for Irene well maybe it's
actually VALIC who feels the connection
between the two women there's also an
Annabelle Croatian Easter egg in the nun
when we get to see again the photograph
of sister Charlotte with three nuns and
Valik that she showed to mr. Mullins in
the Annabelle prequel movie that sister
Maria that sister Anna in that sister
Lucia who's this I don't know I don't
think I even met her I was wondering if
we might actually meet sisters Maria
Anna and Lucia but the fact that they
were never mentioned in the nun movie
makes me think they probably perished at
the hands of Ballack before Irene
arrived like in the country to the nun
also packs a number of hidden VALIC
words into the background of the movie
the first one I noticed is that Val axe
name is hidden in the window frame of
sister Victoria's room you can also see
Val akin part of the periodic table on
the classroom wall and it also appears
as va0 one Lak on the luggage trucks
license plate in addition to that it's
hidden among the trees of the forest
right now it's time to talk about that
big twist that occurs when Irene is
keeping vigil in the chapel she sees
nuns walk into the chapel to pray with
her to keep Vanek at bay but later
they're all tossed aside by the demonic
force the sister Irene continues to pray
in an attempt to hold back the evil
power
Ballack slices of V into her expose
shoulders the carving continues turning
the V into a pentagram marking Irene and
foreshadowing how phallic will later
trick her and lead her into a pentagram
finally possessing her before French she
place his holy blood on her face to cast
out the demon and bring her back
visually this is an impressive scene
however what happens next turns our
understanding of the movie upside down
when sister Irene realizes that none of
the nuns were ever actually there with
her
and at that point it seems like all of
Irene's interactions with the nuns have
just been visions or spirits this
revelation links back to the opening
scene of the movie where sister Victoria
committed suicide it seems like Victoria
knew she was the last surviving nun at
the convent which is why she knew she
had to sacrifice herself so that VALIC
couldn't take her soul and use her as a
vessel to escape and peppered throughout
the movie are clues hinting that the
convent is empty of any living nuns for
example the Abbess whose death herself
won't let anyone into the convent when
they arrived and only Irene is allowed
in the next day also initially when
Irene finds sister Ana dead in the
chapel it looks like she's only just
died
however after Irene's vision disappears
Oh Ana's body is still there but it's
very dark and seems to be decomposing
suggesting Iran has actually been dead
for some time which indicates that
Irene's conversations with Oana were not
with the living nun but rather they were
visions or appearances of Ana's spirit
it's possible many of these visions have
been a trick by foul act to weaken Irene
psychologically and prepare her to be
possessed when she unknowingly walks
into the pentagram basically Val acts
been taking her through the three stages
of demonic activity infestation
oppression and finally possession a
narrative thread left open at the end of
the movie is father Burke's wounded eye
which he suffered when the ghost of
Daniel attacked him with his serpent
tongue which latched itself onto the
father's eye Daniel was a boy who died
when Burke tried to exorcise him
although Burke eventually gets away I
wonder whether he was infected in any
way similar to what happened to Frenchie
overall the plot of the nun seems more
complicated and ambiguous than it needs
to be and although I've laid out my
understanding of the twist based on my
initial viewing I can see there's room
for different interpretations I'd love
to hear your theories and thoughts about
the film and its ending in the comments
below and on Twitter plus do share any
other kind ring connections that you
spotted tapleft to check out some
freakishly creepy facts about the making
of the nun or tap write for more horror
movie videos and if you enjoyed this a
like would be great at a share would be
awesome thanks for watching and see you
next time you became movie lovers